uh
everyone on the stream i'm in the chat
but we're just finishing setup so i have
everyone else muted so you can't hear
them right now
but uh well we'll get it we'll get it
done we'll get it done any second
foreign
hi everyone welcome to the stream
i'm currently playing with my friends
mitch and mel who both worked on this
game
worth noting mel is no longer at studio
and rojo
who you know um is uh apparently in uh
the upcoming season of mandalorian
so excited to have you
that's definitely a real thing right
right and
uh i'm playing with a with a controller
rahul you have a a stick right yeah i've
got a flight stick
oh [ __ ] you're using it now tight i'm
good to go yeah i
it's i just had it arrived today from
amazon so i'm not used to it but i'm
gonna just wing it
nice i was gonna say mitch is playing in
vr
mel how what's your situation controller
just seemed like the right way to play
for me
that's what i've got too i agree it's
how i usually play yeah
see it i'm definitely most effective
with the controller the hotest stuff
frightens me oh have you ever tried
playing uh
oh mitch have you ever played uh
dota with a controller uh yeah yeah
actually i made a video about it for ign
oh did you yeah yeah because i played a
match with the steam controller when
that came out
they were like you could play any game
with this and i was like any game
can you i did once and i found it so
funny
it is so entertaining almost impossible
but technically possible i did win you
can do it
oh okay oh look at you go big three
spell combo with lena it was perfect
uh-huh
yeah you played a lot of a lot of dota
in the ign days i remember that oh yeah
how are you doing you'll be like playing
dota well you don't play dota anymore
no no really no no i just hit six
thousand hours
oh i just didn't trust that makes more
sense i've been playing since 2018.
i'm so sorry i think
i had maybe like maybe like
300 or so um it might have been more
than that back in the day because that's
what like all my friends in high school
just like always wanted to play um and i
my win ratio was like maybe five percent
like just awful should i queue us for a
game by the way
yeah yeah yeah let's go let's go we're
ready we're ready to play the video game
right
carry on i just think so badly i'm
switching to a controller
no but but rahul if it goes badly you
get to use the excuse of oh i don't know
what i'm doing
oh my god
no that's female gamer talk wow
look at him go that's gonna get clipped
out of context enjoy that again i did
try to figure out a way that when mel
said uh that she mostly played with
controller that i could roast her for
being a fake gamer even though she
developed this game
but i really did want to do it i wanted
to be like yeah
[Music]
no i do not like you don't deserve to
get to play this game
the developers put a lot of work into
this and you're not respecting it
you're right
i've only used one of these because i
only did the tutorial i don't know which
one
where are i'm just looking at tie
fighters
all right so honestly tie fighters are
a really great ship to to kind of get
your sea legs with so to speak
they're just really like i don't know
they're not hyper specialized so you can
kind of just
experiment and figure out what your play
style is and then once you figure that
out you can maybe move on to
a different ship that caters to your
play style a little bit all right
we'll go with the tie fighter first to
you oh yeah again you don't walk there
anymore but that was such a great like
the tie fighter is a great ship for if
you want to learn how to play
i turned into a commercial because for
years i helped out with some of the
demos so i was just like
constantly teaching you know internal uh
play tests and stuff like that
helping people on board to the game to
get an overview so it's all just
a great job oh thank you yeah i'm here
to help you i'd let you teach me
anything oh
i aim to please anything anything you
want
i can i can teach you all about uh the
history
my brain's trying to make it a sex joke
but i can't find one
um just pretend i winked oh okay
my other greatest pet sexy dinosaurs sex
dinosaurs what is the sexiest
okay that's the one can you say
cockasole is that what you just said
i said a common source i heard
connoisseur that's also quite good
i like minecraft is really good as well
oh someone in my chat says they think
fifa 20 is going to be game of the year
that's an interesting choice
that came out last year that's my
favorite ea game that released this
month
yes yes definitely the best one that
came out this month i'm being serious
that's all in my top three is it is it
really good this year i don't know
anything about it
okay okay okay okay okay okay that's my
controller it's not
it's more of a cultural thing sure we i
mean it's fifa means it's good kind of
by default
right it's fifa means it's good i think
the fifa community would disagree with
you
yeah yeah i can't
control anything are you going to be
obama are you i will protect you hang on
okay i presently have no input let's
figure it out
figure out what's happened i don't care
for that
you're on a controller on pc yes you're
not in vr yes
i'm not in vr uh stupid question okay
it started working i just pressed start
and here it is okay great we got it we
got it we did it
and i'm going to die and i'm going to
die great okay cool
smash those buttons i'm doing it i'm
doing it i'm doing it yes
i invaded a missile yeah dude a [ __ ]
god move
that's me that's me okay okay hey okay
that's my first multiplayer match
i would just like to say what is
happening uh
well the objective of this game is to
point your guns at the x-wings and then
blow up the x-wings
okay i got an x-wing but i also died but
it's okay i got an achievement
at the top center of the screen we have
the it's like counting up to 30.
first team to 30 kills oh jesus uh first
team to 30 kills
shut up we don't i don't need that kind
of bad energy in my life
listen i just mitchell oh yeah
little face little face yeah
[Laughter]
okay okay okay okay none and i i feel
like this is like
oh well i don't mind that um i gotta
remember to like swap between my like
power options
and that yeah i highly recommend uh
putting everything into engines first to
get a little bit of afterburner going
uh and then switch it over to max lasers
when you get near somebody and then if
they start to get away from you or you
need to escape you can after burner away
this shouldn't be paying you for this
nice shot oh thanks i died
validation i have something incoming
oh i invaded it look at me [ __ ] speed
demon yes uh that's what the
afterburners are for
if ever you don't know what to do just
press your a button and it'll auto
target
uh enemy uh oh jesus christ i'm like
flying through one i've been trying to
kill this same [ __ ] for quite a
while
oh yeah you're again in vr how do you
like it literally in space
it is and i'm not joking kind of a
transcendent experience for me
oh i'm so excited wait oh i died by
pilot era
i feel like i did that i feel like that
means that was your fault yeah
okay
i'm okay uh i think mel has died once
but
you keep fishing onion carriers
onion one dangerous onion coming up
yeah i mean you're not wrong
you have you want to to speak french oh
jesus
i don't even know if that dumb joke i
just made is actual french it's probably
not
mel can you speak french no ma'am cool
you guys are making it work out there in
montreal
it's happening really just making it
happen it's pretty angler friendly here
yeah that's true i feel like
i mean i was surprised when i first went
there by the amount of french that was
actually
present it was definitely a thing it's
definitely more than the rest of canada
uh yeah of course
i've been playing this game for like two
and a half years and i'm still learning
i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm doing i'm
doing my best is what i'm doing
pilot yeah again sometimes you just
gotta commit suicide
mitch oh you have zero kills mitch alana
mitch why are you shaming me hey gamer
boy they don't call you mitch dyer for
no reason
stream is a fake gamer girl it's me for
sure
[Laughter]
six thousand hours in total maximum
gaming is on four why is nobody [ __ ]
roasting him
see i'm trying to evade evade these here
missiles that are coming for me oh i did
it okay it's actually pretty doable
yeah if you do a lot of loop-de-loops
and twists and turns
uh they they shake off like the
spongebob stuff yeah yes
exactly i'm glad you caught that i'm
focusing i'm trying to kill this guy
there we go that's
okay we'll allow that oh i avenged
someone
nice i'm proud of me you can also hit b
and that'll fire a countermeasure
that'll
potentially stop the missile coming
after you as well okay well i think that
i don't know what stopped that missile
from coming at me but something it could
have collided with something or someone
else
somebody also you can shoot missiles
down so if you see one coming you can
just
fire on it and save someone's life yeah
it ranges about a thousand so if it's
when that
you should stop blocking missiles on me
you [ __ ] punks
who's doing it i'm coming to kill them
i'm gonna do something [ __ ] useless i
don't even know
let's go i'm not
sure or is it my missile that is locking
am i reading the ui
incorrectly i don't know no it's
incoming i may have been
trying to lock it myself and uh
misunderstood that that may have
happened
oh it's all good if you're locking on
somebody else the white brackets around
the person you're looking at will start
to have a second bracket that will turn
green
he wasn't looking at anyone that's why i
thought it was wrong yeah
that would be from someone else then
welp welp
mitch i swear to god i'm i'm doing my
best
but i do love that someone who literally
had the balls to name themselves maximum
gaming
i was thinking that it had to be like a
website or a brand like is that a thing
well do you think that's a bot oh
no no the bots all have character names
that i wrote
oh yeah how difficult i don't know i
don't want to make this a a work
interview but how
hard is that process of making um star
wars names that get passed by star wars
uh usually it's okay this is gonna be
difficult to explain again while being
murdered in space it's fine no that's
fat
uh jesus uh the approvals process for
riding star wars is not like a crazy
difficult thing
it's not like a gauntlet where you have
to like pass tests or anything it's
really just
is this creatively beneficial for the
story does this
make sense for star wars does it feel
right okay cool
and that's that's obviously like a
really reductive way to summarize years
of creative work but
yeah it's it's not that bad yeah it's
not bad
sometimes it takes refining like there's
stuff that like we pitched a bunch of
names and things and it was like
it doesn't quite work or it sounds kind
of similar to this thing or you know
sometimes you
like you make a name and you're like oh
actually that's like a character from
this other ip i wasn't thinking of and
we don't want to
like crib that name um as it turns out a
lot of star wars characters that exist
yes something i'm also noticing over
time is like how many
from like old to you to new star wars or
whatever how many characters have like
the same
name like if you look up the name ray in
any spelling
there's like 45 different rays in star
wars
oh really yeah there's so many
oh defeat imminent oh heck
okay i'm going to step it up and start
getting kills
look yeah i should be paying more
attention to what i'm doing but also
i will um major complaint i have to add
with you folk about this game
it's really pretty i think i get
distracted by how pretty it is yeah look
at it though
even like the fidelity in vr morning
phenomenal i'm really surprised
so what are you using a wrist oculus
yeah okay
i have a quest uh you could use the
steam or the steam like sorry the oculus
link
to uh give it a shot to play it i
believe i would certainly like to
um yeah so the best thing to do right
now actually is not die and i'll clean
up damn it
why didn't you say that like eight
minutes sooner
the carry strat is literally just could
you stop dying and i can take care of it
okay we follow mel next time yeah i'll
play support and just
fire health at you that's my first time
sounds great what's the flight sick
experience like i've literally never
used one
i loved it yeah yeah oh great you did
well too i felt like it was more
accurate than when i used the pad on the
playstation last night
that is awesome are you on a console
right now are you playing console hotels
there you go yeah yeah my dad's playing
on please love to see him play with him
this weekend
uh friends on xbox can join us people
playing
oh that's great any pc with any
controller set up at all
it's all compatible that rules yeah man
the future of video games is
it's here and it's awesome i mean yeah i
think the fact that you're playing in vr
with us is dub
yeah it's like like i i use vr to walk
out
every single day at this point and i
think like
that's it's like 20 i never would have
expected to be at a point
where i used vr every single day what
are you playing to work out
are you playing mostly supernatural uh
on oculus i think it's an okay
exclusive it has an expensive
subscription but it kicks my ass like
it's
hard um but i do a lot of beat saber as
well because the more fun option
where it still gets you sweaty but like
i have a great time so that's the cheat
one
do you have like the silicone masks and
stuff so you don't totally destroy your
headsets or you just rock yeah i bought
i bought all all i bought extra pads and
a silicone mask recently but i have
broken a controller because i punched my
fridge
so it didn't break it just stopped
vibrating yeah
so yeah it's still sort of a bubba a
keyframe yeah in
[Laughter]
i'm going to stay with the fighter
because i suck
i think i can actually support this
round and just try to keep people alive
support would be amazing um i find so
what's the support
what is that what is that so with
support chips you can do a few things
a lot of it is disruption you can
disrupt enemy fighters by hitting them
with tractor beams or disabling their
ability to use cancer measures
um the most useful for dog fighting i
find
uh at least early on when everyone's
getting their bearings is the resupply
droid so mitch can
give us back health and ammo throughout
the match yeah
and it kind of gets deployed in these
green orbs that you'll see they respond
randomly in the map
organically but there's organically like
they're birthed by a resupply droid
but there's uh you can also have them
fired out by
support chips if you need extra ones and
they're just available to you
okay what engine is ideal on the tie
reaper microthrust
uh microthrust is fine it's less good
for the reaper because you've not
necessarily dog fighting doesn't occur
to me
that was a thing that i could also look
at and now
yeah yeah someone in my chat just
mentioned uh
they asked if my stream was desynced and
i just want to say it was thank you for
pointing that out
i had a 500 uh yeah 500 millisecond
delay on my speech
which is actually nuts that you even
noticed because it's such a small amount
of time really
uh but yes it was i apologize i have
fixed it now thank you glad you pointed
it out
it's because of elgato captcha if i
capture from elgato which i most
recently did for
crash bandicoot for phone house it's
oh my god it's crash 4 i really like it
it's really good
um but for whatever reason my brain
response to playing crash 4 was to go
back
rather than continuing on crash four
like
as soon as i finished playing it i was
like i'm gonna play more of the insane
trilogy and i still don't know why
my brain did that it was like why didn't
i just keep playing crash four
like no i have to finish them
chronologically but like the old ones
are [ __ ] hard and i'm so bad
at platformers that it's true they're
brutal
i had the first two growing up and i was
just like god
so frustrating why is the game screaming
at me
to get ready it's so
uh we're entering my favorite map in the
whole game my favorite location
it's my favorite location of the
campaign it's my favorite location
multiplayer
it is so cool my screen currently says
uh danger boy says yes
uh what is that hell yeah ninja boy yes
yeah i just said danger boys
yes hell yes danger boy hell yeah dude
i don't know what you're saying
yesterday but i agree maybe a dangerous
danger boy it's a dangerous team that's
what everyone called mitch dyer at ign
when we walked together they were like
oh he's
danger boy
that's not true that was me that was me
he's so dangerous dangerous
he's got a threatening presence no we
actually mostly called him
uh [ __ ] crier [ __ ] crier
which i still find very funny it's
really good
oh [ __ ] crying people on the internet
call me that trying to be hurtful and
i'm like you don't
understand my friends at all oh you
don't know how much [ __ ] brian altano
has given me over the years [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] that's so funny [ __ ] okay so
actually i'm helping my team hang on i
gotta i'm not [ __ ] together uh no
they've already been targeted
take some [ __ ] healing oh i can't did
it work
yep one step at a time i really stopped
looking me you punks yes danger boy
yes danger boys that's doing [ __ ]
great
okay uh a fun feature when you're locked
on to someone
if you press the y button and sorry raul
i have no idea what it is
if you press the y button you will ping
whatever you're targeting oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah
and it's just like a nice way to say
like oh i'm attacking this guy
and then i can also ping him and like
knowledge
so now we're focusing on the same dude
okay look there are a lot of layers to
this that i feel like is going to take
me a while to learn and i don't think
the fact that i've decided to drink two
white clothes before doing this was
my best decision um but i have faith
that i will pull through and thank [ __ ]
we have mel on our team
oh this idiot stopped in front of me the
disrespect
what happened should i kill someone for
you i will simp don't you make me sin
simp [ __ ] dangerous onion i swear to god
i'll do it
i don't know what that word means oh
well okay so
fun fact um simp is really just another
term that we've invented to tell people
to stop even being nice to women
um which is my favorite but
[Laughter]
what it actually stands for oh oh that
man died uh it's it's something like
uh it's like scrubs uh and something to
do with mediocre [ __ ]
so if you call someone a simp you are
also calling whichever woman they are
being nice to
mediocre [ __ ] so anyone who pretends
it's like
not just like aggressively sexist is
kidding themselves
naturally yeah damn it i'm uh
so okay is the best strat for evading a
missile what i think i need to do
is go full power in my engines and then
do tight turns
exactly or am i better to like drop
throttle halfway and
i need to oh yeah go to the go to the
sweet spot with everything in your
engines and you'll be
you'll be dancing around it no problem
okay okay okay yeah like if you're max
pips
these fish got [ __ ] nine kills i know
i just saw
what
i love that it tells you when things are
out of range i'm a fan of that
no that took me out [ __ ] sake ah
okay i ran out of charge is what
happened to you my missile isn't coming
we're just gonna do twisty turns we
didn't do anytime
i definitely feel like i shouldn't have
had alcohol before this particular
gameplay session it's i've it's
feeling bad i'm just like i'm not even
tracking what's happening and it isn't
uh but
she says while opening another white
cloth you guys ready
so ready naturally it's quite a lot to
take in i understand
i hate carrios though look at you
[ __ ] go mel
what the [ __ ] oh god i don't know if
mitch mentioned
i don't want to break i'm very good at
this game uh he didn't mention that and
i think that i appreciate it because i
feel like i got like blindsided by the
skill
um yeah males are ace in the hole yeah
absolutely
again it's so pretty reactivated yeah
dude i can't get any movement done
because of him [ __ ] you know wait is
there a particular person on the enemy
team
some guy just keeps [ __ ] like tabling
smells like a
like a pissed off who is it bullying you
at school
give
i think that is what happened best of
the worst well you say that but
i'm worried when you're targeted what's
the best way to evade it
i haven't got anything i'm just using
the tie fighter
uh counter measures are okay
countermeasures are good
oh i just ran right into him oh
into engines uh try doing uh
some some turns with your engine set
full in the sweet spot and then once you
get an after burner charge
use that to get away and then get some
distance someone in my chat
said that they think that i should take
a drink whenever mel gets a kill
are you trying to kill me you'll be dead
in 10 minutes
i don't think that's a good idea at all
who's the user name on that
because i'm happy with someone we know
it was jeff who actually is in my chat
quite frequently
good dude good dude but uh trying to
kill me
apparently okay
i need to change i need to evade i need
to evade i think one of the the issues
that i'm having with my own strat
is um once i target someone i just chase
them at
the expense of everything which is not
my best big tunnel vision
yeah pretty much if it
helps mel i would love it if you plea
like don't even be apologetic mansplain
the [ __ ] out of this to me
okay so in order to avoid tunnel vision
it's it's best to kind of treat it like
a sprint instead of a marathon
so yeah uh try keeping up with somebody
if you miss like enough shots to deplete
your lasers
off switch back to lasers and kind of
disconnect for a second and reevaluate
where you're going because
it can be easy to get lead into the fog
or inside an enemy team that way so
yeah exactly oh mitch you resupplied me
i did yeah exactly it was my dying
breath start yelling if you need healing
so that mitch can find you
okay i'm good i'm gonna avoid this
missile as best i can
again i think you did healing this how
can you take damage
just because it can happen so fast like
if you're under attack just call it
got it uh you can hold y and hit up and
you'll hit
uh you'll hit it with a help me and i'm
dead
all right i'll also take
targets if that helps that way yeah yeah
yeah
i can i can you guys can just focus on
whoever i'm chasing and then i'll
protect you guys as you go after that
target okay um someone in my chat said
alana tell those devs to stop playing
and go fix the pc version
have you considered doing more work on
your friday night
you you're doing work lazy well the [ __ ]
is your bell doesn't even work very well
sure i'll get right on that uh literally
all of us are playing the pc version
rahul and i had this conversation uh not
that long ago about oh it's my favorite
thing in the world who was it you'd
remember better than me
yeah so rod ferguson had tweeted
something about like his anniversary
with his wife and someone was like fixed
gears of war
she's just like you you complete me he
wrote like the sweetest message so
funny like shotguns bro
yeah it's so funny
like just oh the sweetness of a personal
post with someone just being like their
nasher
sucks bro it's just hilarious to me
oh just incredible uh mitchie do you
play gs5
i know you're a good fan yeah we loved
it
i was in that game so i love elana
pierce's gears 5. thank you
thank you appreciate it we did we spent
a lot of time in that camp trying to
find you
well did you find me we found you that
rules i bet you didn't find rahul
because he's not in the game no no we
missed him completely yeah he's super
easy to miss
years of war i had no idea oh my god
he's false he's fast i know
i know oh oh sorry oh [ __ ] we got done
oh she's too galaxy brand dude i can't
take it
smelled escaped she's 15 and four now
and that's what she just did to us
i know is she pulling that [ __ ] while
winning like are you kidding
me i was playing 40 chess while playing
squadrons
for three years all i did was snark at
my teammates and my my colleagues while
playing this game
this is my home now you got you've got
basically the like the maximum training
he's gonna [ __ ] heal did i get him
did i get him
i think he's the one doing the weird all
right oh that is that
was correct no i got tunnel vision again
damn it alana it keeps happening thank
you
okay oh did we win we did win thank you
um i really appreciate uh all of you
joining me
when i carried the team there got us
through that victory
um holy [ __ ] that was a close game it
was 30 29.
thank god for mel it's a good thing you
killed that guy when you did because i
was about to goof into a wall
wait so you are you actually a medic or
did you just get an award for being a
medic
i got the award because i was healing a
bunch of support i don't know how any
other class would get that
award but classic [ __ ] i think it's
just it's just recognizing
my amazing healing contribution to this
team that won
i appreciate
hey uh people have been saying that
that's what people have been saying
they've been
like this [ __ ] backbone of of the the
entire game actually so
yeah i'm just reporting what the fans
are saying you're like mel who
that onion's not even dangerous i'm not
scared 15 and what who
cares
it's like that onion is like mildly
inconvenient
they get worse more of a decorative
onion
am i still cracked at gears i am still
pretty [ __ ] good at gears
chat nice still quite good i love a good
horde mode
in a while i haven't either actually i
actually didn't finish gears 5 i should
really go back and yeah
sorry rahul that's fine i've been
meaning to break this finest work is in
the third act alone
well i did watch all of holly quinn oh
hell yeah rahul is also skeptical it was
all wonderful yeah
we're watching that right now and having
a great [ __ ] time with it it's a
really good show i enjoyed it
it's shockingly excellent i didn't think
i would ever care about
a dc show this much but i really love it
wow okay that's a stance
what's wrong what do you see oh nothing
sorry i didn't mean to sound rude
oh no you're fine i don't work for dc
it's not rude
oh no i do i technically do because
roasted
is where we're literally in partnership
with water i forgot that that is
actually a thing
technically i do work for dc oh my bad
it was more of a more of a statement on
the fact that i just haven't really
interacted with a lot of dc meetings i
mean and all of them movies
recently have been bad and yeah no i
think hollywood is one of the best
spin off and they say the [ __ ] word a
lot and it's it's really violent
my favorite joke is um
uh i don't remember what his name is but
he calls wonder woman
oh oh yeah everything or whatever
everything with scarecrow is number one
number two is dude calling uh one woman
a [ __ ] and then everyone being like oh
bro what the [ __ ]
you're just like oh [ __ ] dude that was
very funny
it might even be bleeped in the show or
does he actually say it i don't remember
uh they bleeped it did they yeah because
the presentation is it's all
it's all news broadcasts it's so funny
yeah
i absolutely lost my [ __ ] at uh wayne
or bruce wayne's kid
oh yeah he's like this crappy teenager
yeah shitty 13 year old yeah
[ __ ] ruined so good yeah that was
jacob tremblay the the actor he's
oh really amazing who is that i don't
know
he was in that movie you liked with
those three kids like
the seth rogen one not super bad dude oh
um
good boys it may have been cold yeah and
he was also in um doctor sleep
uh i still need to see that clean doctor
sleep is great
i'm not my flanagan joint no i'm just
saying it don't matter
hey it's not that you're currently
working for him or anything
no no right no i'm not sure right
yeah can be very much looking forward to
your television program raul
oh thanks yeah next uh friday oh it's
gonna be good
that's awesome yeah yeah oh i apologize
sorry my one of my someone in my chat
got kind of mad at me for saying [ __ ]
uh as an australian it's not a problem
it's not an issue in australia and
they're english and
canadian mel are you actually canadian i
am there you go so we have no u.s people
on the stream
it's the word is not a problem sorry i
cut you off there a hole when does uh
when does the show come out october
i thought i was talking about well it's
like real soon isn't it
it's next friday that's nice that's
crazy yeah
i love this television show the one that
would he's doing now is better than
everything it's insane the one that he's
doing now is better than everything
yeah i can't really talk about it but
i'm just saying that midnight mass is
like
holy [ __ ] i can't believe that we're
doing this
um it's better than bligh
i feel like your show hasn't even come
out and you're like well this new thing
is better so
good stuff good stuff i'm good at pr in
that
[Laughter]
i mean you you and mitch i don't know
what your stance is smell but i assume
you've probably been there like probably
two of the biggest star wars fans that i
know
so you you're probably pretty excited
about uh mike flanagan's mandalorian
episode
uh that you're definitely working on
because you're ezra right
i told you not i told you before you
press play uh stream sorry that i
wouldn't talk about it
that's not what he said
[ __ ] i'm gonna crash
cackling up a storm in this cockpit i'm
gonna die mitch did we ever talk about
the
banning i'm shooting mel what am i doing
here
we're red bulls i'm so scared i'll see
you later i've been talking
oh my gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh i've
got you i've got you
i i like the x-wing i'm a big fan i got
them
yeah it's a good one my the a-wing is my
my very very favorite ship has been
pretty much since day one and
i'm just so glad it's out here in the
world finally
what did you do specifically obviously
mitch you're a writer but uh mel what
did you specifically work on
i specifically worked on the capital
ships um
i was the head of the i uh
words sorry
i i was the the primary designer on the
captorship experience so i
designed all the the subsystems and the
the tuning and the kind of experience
around the
the flagships and the capital ships with
a team of very cool people
and i love you all so much and the
championships turned out great
battles they sure [ __ ] did yeah
people
uh i mean i was saying this before the
stream but the reviews seem to be pretty
positive people seem to be pretty stoked
about about a lot of
nice form reception it's been lovely
yeah it's nice and
it was exciting like on a personal note
i was a junior prior to squadron so i
had never really worked on a big feature
before so that was the first time i was
ever like
given a really big thing to to
like tackle and be the the point of
contact for and the rules it was really
really fun i really loved it you guys
both also worked on battlefront 2
correct
yeah indeed [ __ ] i'm dead i didn't know
that i just wanted to say it for the
stream
i worked mostly as a level designer on
all the the space beats of the levels so
i
was kind of already doing starfighter
stuff for
for for like on a dev side for a while
so when squadron started spinning up
everyone was like mel's your gal i was
like oh [ __ ]
that's so cool what that rules also guys
i'm doing well
oh congrats yeah dude so
that's happening and i don't want to
alarm anyone
something's going to go wrong i'm going
to ionize this
reaper if anyone wants to oh i'll kill
it put it out of its [ __ ] misery
thank you very much all right get on me
with your [ __ ] [ __ ]
no you don't no you don't no you don't
no you don't no
no you don't um
yeah me td i remember uh you know we
worked together at ign when you you left
to go ride a star war
i know um that's pretty it was pretty
crazy [ __ ]
it was it was someone like leaving to do
a thing that like
they were made for like if that makes
sense like
i was like yeah no he writes he loves
star wars like of course
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] this star wars test tube
baby can be put to you
my first death there was almost uh just
me crashing into something so
that's a thing that almost happened nice
work dangerous onion
nice work nope there you go on my team
i keep getting a lot of assists i don't
know what my actual
amount of kills is going to be but my
guess is yeah i got so many assists
i've got three assists but mel still has
10 kills
yeah it's like somebody quit the game or
lost connection to the server
in unranked which is what we're playing
now it doesn't really matter
somebody will just replace them or they
can reconnect
oh i'm gonna die [ __ ] i was just coming
to you isn't that kind of always the
case of being abandoned
you know someone can always just replace
them it doesn't really matter
dad i love my dad i'm still very close
i need to go swap over to my lasers
here we go [ __ ] you ballast today [ __ ]
oh you committed suicide again
oh my gosh i got that kill you got him
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
okay okay who are you scotcha uh that's
actually a pretty good name i can't hate
oh i'm gonna die no mel what will we do
without you
i have died carry on well i guess i'll
just
let's just throw the game there's no
point [ __ ] missile locks
you sons of [ __ ] okay
i uh my alcohol brain is having trouble
definitely with with uh
disconnecting the missile locks that are
on me with my own target lock
so i need to do a better job of
comprehending that
all right i'm going after your target
mitchell i don't even know who i'm mark
sorry i changed the focus because one of
our dudes is about to die
okay i'm going to kill this guy then
because he's so
very yeah you just do that to all of
them
until we win which wow we all win it we
are
winning like buy like buy like a lot um
oh my god there's a whole [ __ ]
squadron on me nice i shot him i got him
that was insanely badass um i'm dead
no [ __ ] i couldn't get them in time i'm
actually um
when i was playing through the tutorial
which was right before we started
i was worried that swapping between uh
the three
like power modes of um
an x-wing would bother me but it's
actually like very organic like it's
not difficult at all like i'm not having
trouble remembering which ones which i
am having trouble
with other things that are my own fault
but um not that
that's that's that makes you feel any
better that would be really nice
thank you [ __ ] i appreciate you
stop incoming just leave me alone bro no
more leave with you bro
oh oh again oh mellow your [ __ ]
a-wing skin is
so cool yeah i got the black one i like
the pink one
goth anyway oh my god it's i've seen all
of these skins a million times
and being in vr and seeing an a-wing
with like a really cool paint job and
just flying by it
so [ __ ] cool why did you like work on
the game or something
not to brag oh [ __ ] as i crash and die
oh mitchell i saw that i feel like i'm
doing really bad but at least
mistake is doing worse you know
oh good stuff
okay okay okay okay okay get off oh i've
got you i'm coming yeah how are you
doing
cool quiet out there i haven't focused
for me oh he's right behind you
oh [ __ ] i just threw healing behind you
because i'm an idiot i'm following you i
should have it up again in a sec
that's fucker's dead you're safe oh nice
one thank you mel
good looking out all right let's [ __ ]
go scotcher
target lost huh wow i got [ __ ] he he
got me quite bad there
that was
i got him thank you nice again all you
i got barely any kills on that one it's
all right
same but we still won
what matters is that we got the w yes
again thank you mel i really appreciate
your time
thank you for your service that's what
i'm here for
uh how much do i owe you for this
oh if we can get to level five and do a
fleet battle that would be sick
yeah that seems close it doesn't take
that long
it's like three to five matches i think
oh you can only stop
beat battles at level five yeah yeah
ranked ranked mode gotcha
and there's a lot to learn obviously so
it's like please spend some time in
dogfight and
get your training wheels gotcha
because even in dogfights there's a lot
to figure out
yeah i didn't realize that you had like
healers and stuff like that i just
thought it was just
ship to ship with different yeah and
it's
it's the support like you can play it as
a healer and
probably should but there are other
builds that could
empower your team in other ways
depending on the component you unlock
i should pay more attention to that
probably yeah
there's a lot like i i only now just
start to feel like i really have a good
grip on it
and that took 10 hours you're saying
yeah and several years
now that all the pieces are in place
it's like ah this is how the game works
and this is how the career flows
this is what the progression is like how
long is the campaign
the single player i've i don't
know i'm playing through it now and i
haven't played it start to finish in the
complete version but
i read many reviews saying six seven
eight hours
okay longer than battlefront which is
the question i get most
oh because battlefront was four or five
it was pretty short yeah it was pretty
short
i like the campaign though i had a good
time well i'm fond of it as well
what's a good um laser for the
x-wing just the standard one or would
you upgrade
i like the burst one a lot because it
fires uh the four guns at the same time
and it does like a burst and then a
cooldown and a burst to cool down and it
chunks out a lot of damage at once
uh i think it feels really satisfying if
you can hit your targets they just
evaporate really fast
especially against like interceptors or
tie fighters
oh sweet okay i'm gonna try obama this
time
and that that goes the same for like
when you're using the tie fighter right
yeah i like the burst on the on the tie
fighter as well i
tend to stick with standard on tie
fighter just because i like the
the laser clip like it feels really good
to have two lasers firing that fast as
opposed to
the x-wing which has four lasers firing
in a burst instead of one at a time
gotcha yeah this is like way more
customizable than i
expected too actually
you can get
because that's empire strikes back and
return of the jedi what are you some
kind of star wars dart
well i'm painting the models in it
yeah that's fast
yeah i really like putting paint jobs
okay you know that that's nice yeah twin
slam engine is really good
i highly recommend it on uh reapers and
bombers because it just kind of
constantly i'm thinking of the right one
just constantly builds up your
your afterburner so you don't have to
necessarily have your stuff in engines
as often you can just kind of get out of
sticky situations a little better that
way
okay yeah i'm trying the bomb this time
around i just uh
i just used that in my support craft and
it was very nice to not have to
have power in my engines the whole time
like i could i could max shields but
still also
boost and drift and be highly
maneuverable but also super defensible
you just uh you just punch a headset
that mitch maybe
i can't see i'm trying to take a drink
of water
that always happens to me when like like
i said mid workout in vr or i'm trying
to take a sip of water and i have to
sort of like
look like you have to tilt your head
backwards so you can see the room to try
to even find the water
and then try to zip it it's a whole
[ __ ] thing
someone in my chat asked is this running
on frostbite
it sure is it's a good engine
it is a powerful powerful thing i mean
yeah coley we were just talking about
this the other day how
frostbite real pretty just
real pretty and it's it's gorgeous on pc
like the battlefield games and and
battlefront
yeah yeah like i'm surprised at the
fidelity of this game in vr
is because normally the downscaling is
so noticeable
but in this it like it's you know it's a
it's a it's noticeably different but
jesus christ it looks so
good in vr like it maintains enough
fidelity
it's fantastic all right let's kill this
guy fantastic
oh jesus hi mel are we talking about the
mockingmire
no i'm just shooting a rock
i'll soften them up you guys finish them
off uh yeah i'm totally going to
contribute
oh i'm here i'm useful yes got 13
following direction oh i like this new
gun that i equipped actually but i still
haven't hit him once so
um teamwork [ __ ]
you guys got this i believe oh [ __ ] i
couldn't get that y wing oh my gosh
so low this [ __ ] [ __ ] i wouldn't
worry too much about
um at least target prioritization is
pretty hard because there's a lot going
on in the script so whoever kind of
crosses your vision
okay because i just changed to the
bomber
and i did change a couple of things
there's definitely already a significant
difference
in my speed that i think is going to
take some adjustment like a way more
dramatic difference than i expected
which i appreciate oh yeah
bombers are quite a bit slower they're
great in fleet battles they're pretty
challenging
in dogfights i won't lie okay i just
spawned straight into
whoa that's unfair yeah you should
complain to the developers
i just spoke that rock moved right away
have you tried not spawning there
[Laughter]
[ __ ] hell come on
okay nope
just avoiding giant rocks
[Music]
being targeted
have some health i
have i ever told you how much i love you
mitch daya have i ever
expressed that it's uh i love a good
heal
bro
all right kill this idiot oh you like
healing have more
healing dude oh my god thank you
okay i think we still haven't killed him
i feel like i've gotten a million shots
off on that dude
there we go we did it we did it
thank you guys you're the mvp i mean mel
is but still you're like
like second like surely second i am just
here to help
well you're doing a great job i'm here
to give space so you guys can learn
um okay that was pretty tidy
that was pretty tidy mitch we i think we
just did that
okay hmm
so far i've had like one good game um
no no you're not okay no you're not
locked on
because i'm gonna do sort of this i did
evade it okay i'm getting better at that
that's happening nice that's a that's
half the battle honestly
i'm so bad at missile vision i mean i'm
still not perfect i'm just
improving i think hell yes
oh no i got them i'm in the water i
can't either dude
they're all awake so fast
they're all pretty tiny ow [ __ ] uh
broken demo disc this is already out on
ps4
today yeah i could have sworn i had
kills but i actually
was 40 dollars only 40 dollars
okay yeah i'm dead i can't
i'm having a rough one too many
i can't okay yeah
i'm coming to you holy [ __ ] okay no
wonder roll you have literally all five
of them are chasing you
oh is that wrong i hate you man or is he
actually dead
i'm just getting [ __ ] hammered here
yeah it's probably a race thing
i've got two assists
[Music]
i will try to protect is one of these
voice actors australian
i feel like someone threw my headphones
just said that was close and i was like
do i have a brother i don't know about
all right again oh no [ __ ] i was right
behind you i was about to heal you no
whatever he's that's two in a row for
him cory baxter's got my number he's got
me three times now
yeah i bet that next god of war is going
to be [ __ ] anyway
i got four [ __ ] pretty proud of that
joke
i killed myself i made a good joke and
then i peaced out
nice he died all right
oh rahul you all having a tough game
you okay boss man we got a boy adrift
over here
whoops
someone in my chat said thai bombers
opie if equipped properly i'm probably
not that well equipped frankly right now
and again that's a minor repair i got
you this time i got you
oh thanks mitch i got hit i think i've
got it
no oh i tried to disable this a-wing
after you two
i'm coming i've got rid of him just
could you oh my god i haven't even had
eyes on anyone
and i've taken three hits [ __ ] off dude
there's a lot of places to hide in this
map because it's enormous so there's so
much debris
with all the rocks oh it's pronounced
deborah's
deborus no that was bad
come on nope
they evaded these guys are pretty
slippery what i find is
these guys are good i gained smaller
ships is doing bursts of fire because
you run out of lasers so fast
disabling this guy like trying to hunt
somebody down
rahul i'm on my way to you all right are
we going off the moss is this a real
thing we're doing
yeah that i disabled like the hit psvr
title
oh i love that game right how good is it
i was thinking of the guy from the iit
crowd
also good also a good show
[ __ ] just stopped moving good
stuff
just get him [ __ ]
all right i have to go for a cigarette
i had a game a few hours ago that i'm i
just lived your experience where like i
spawned i was dead i spawned i was dead
i couldn't catch a [ __ ] break yeah
there's no reason why right it's just
the gods get
just [ __ ] missile locks man five
deaths
i can't get a kill i had like six kills
in the last game
i'm having trouble here too fam for sure
mel's not though right mel
of course right no my best yeah well
your best is pretty [ __ ] good so
let's kill this
no sweat i appreciate you i appreciate
that the mvp says no
no sweat that means a lot take it out
[ __ ] you corey it's pretty straight
far stretch for me to feel like i don't
know you imagine playing with somebody
for the first time i've been
working on this game for three years
then just being like wow you guys suck
yeah that would be a [ __ ] you on my
level god
oh this guy's really really really low
[ __ ] oh
gosh oh gosh oh gosh 20 health [ __ ] off
cory
suck and i died defeat
imminent not very cool guys i got a kill
i gotta kill
i'm very proud of me and it was corey so
victory uh hey mel should i just like
stay away from everyone and let you get
full kills right now i'm happy if i can
do it is that the strat that we should
be doing
annihilates them yes where's number two
no enemy locking i hey look i my strat
right now is to avoid you so
mel can win um please leave me alone
for some reason they're not listening
even though i explicitly said it they
haven't left me alone
that's pretty that's pretty sexy yeah
i don't know i'm gonna do that i got
nope oh
i just i really do want to stay away you
might be oh thank you [ __ ]
rock and then i died yeah
extra [ __ ] okay oh no i was the killing
blow
[ __ ] we tried i let us down
uh rahul someone in my chat just
referred to you as rahul
the guy who makes jacob turn into a
pervert
which is very true you're not wrong
you bring it out of him i have look look
at my top thing
10 missiles and missile surveillance all
i contributed with me
it ranked me as um hyperactive
which probably isn't something that i
should be proud of
i don't think i don't know if that's
what you want
[Laughter]
the chat has asked me to ask the devs if
you can rank your
uh your favorite star wars films
but that's a that is a controversial
opinion in 2020 you can't just be asking
people that on a first date problems
i know you can't just be thrown out yeah
but i can make it really easy it's eight
and then everything else
[ __ ] mitch i think even though i know
what you're doing
a little bit of stick came in my mouth
i'm also being completely genuine he is
yeah that's the thing
and i disagree and i accept that that's
fine it's okay i still love you
but right we do disagree yeah right but
that's yeah that is fine
yeah you you you say eight's the best
and i say that
seven eight and nine never happened
it's two very different stages and we
can still be friends
yeah crazy how that works yeah
yep um well i mean but my favorite is uh
a new hope which nobody ever agrees with
no that's
that is a rare pick i know really but i
really love that movie it's something
about the um
i think it's what gets me about a lot of
video games my second favorite one
pierce
like well that's probably not that
uncommon though
being my first favorite is what's weird
about it is i think that
everyone picks empire that's awesome
yeah i love the
uh the experience of just like the fresh
eyes on a new world that doesn't have
that much
exposition like they're just the getting
to experience the star wars world
and also that that story is very
self-contained um
yeah so it's not the one that i
necessarily objectively think is the
best or anything i just
very much enjoy watching that movie i
think it's such a
just wonderful is the word that i always
want to use very well
very good it is a delight very good way
to describe it
full of wonder it's a full of wonder
it's
yeah it's so like if if another and no
other star wars movies have ever
happened like the ending is pretty
complete in its own so it feels like a
little bit like watching something
totally separate well because it was
supposed to be right it was supposed to
be a standalone
it would like it actually scoped out
like
this ridiculous backstory and complex
political structure of like the history
of that galaxy like he had scoped out a
bunch of that stuff
um but i don't know that he genuinely
wanted to make them into films or if it
was just like this is
the world building this is what exists
yeah
yeah like i've seen a bunch of stories
about how he was always going to do nine
movies and
other times where it's like well he did
this one but he also had a lot of ideas
for other films
that would be prequels and sequels yeah
at the time right he's the number one
impression that i would like to be able
to nail i can only do the whole
well so i you know i when i was making
star wars i don't know
faster more intense alone i think you
can get a lot more progress on this game
[ __ ] i got hyperactive in the last game
okay
doesn't it get more hyper i just love
the words
someone else can be more uh hyperactive
you just gotta be
faster more intense hyperactive um maybe
i'll make a good film
uh skywalker i just love the way he
talks it's so good
i really need to practice though i can i
can favorite george lucas
anything is just it's for children it's
for children where's for children
anytime anybody gets mad about so it's
for children
i love him i love him i love him too a
lot
i really [ __ ] love george lucas like
aggressively think he's fantastic
i wrote him a letter when i was 14
15 and i broke into healing studios to
deliver it to him while he was doing
pickups for attacking no
[ __ ] and i got this i got yeah
i gotta escort it off and like and i'm
sorry i was such a i'm still a [ __ ]
idiot but like
i made no effort the address was
something like george lucas
attack like star wars ealing studios and
i figured that that would get to him
yeah it'll find him
yeah and then um it was just to say like
i love you you changed my life
i i want to be can i be in star wars
even as a background uh yeah
and then i started acting because of
star wars right yeah yeah yeah
that's the only reason i became an actor
was being star wars so i went to drama
school because i thought well
my letter obviously didn't impress him
so i wanted to learn i can't believe
wrong
that's it still this it's always going
to be there i think i care less about
ever
making it happen because now i just love
my job like i just love the craft i i
found something that i actually enjoy
doing that has nothing to do with star
wars but right but that's easy to say
when you're in the mandalorian
[Laughter]
caravas
[Laughter]
oh man holmes
sorry my cat's on my computer do not
step on that button
come here oh no oh no almost
taking the wheel oh i'm still a little
bugger got the yolk
oh [ __ ] yeah i love this map i got my
red
interceptor oh you do look how much
cooler you are than all of us oh my god
oh man so badass
yeah that's cool living my fantasy guys
you're making me feel so good right now
yeah well you are at some point i'm
actually gonna make
i'm gonna have to get the bandaid
interceptor and paint it red for you
oh that would be fun i'll make it and
i'll do that for you i would love that
you'll have to wait because all my
stuff's in los angeles and i don't know
when i can go home but i'll do that
i would love that that's a that's a nice
thing to look forward to someday
i love a good tentative gift it's good
to have hope
yeah yeah sure ah [ __ ] this
yes i got a kill straight out of the
gate okay oh [ __ ] i'm
[ __ ] disabled i'm going to crash no
did i get that kill i did oh my god i am
talking
oh my god hey i'm probably oh my god
i got a [ __ ] kill oh
my god come here
are you proud of a smell are you proud
all right here we go here we go [ __ ] off
big shot
there you go [ __ ] ruin your day fam
that's what i like to see [ __ ] off big
shot is my favorite star wars quote
they fly now
get that bloodlust going
all right all right yeah it's i mean i
don't like killing anyone who has
dog in that name but that's fair
comment what if his name was like dog
murderer
well okay that'd be great we're gonna
say something else mitch do you remember
when we used to walk around san
francisco and we would um clap anytime
we saw a dog
a little golf club we wouldn't even
acknowledge the human we would just
straight up
clap any time we saw
i told mel and i make this dumb joke all
the time but i always feel like i missed
out on like
plenty of like a lifetime of good
conversations with cute girls in san
francisco
because i just saw their dog and was
i just like ignored the person like no
you don't get hella oh i'm talking to
them i don't even look at them leave me
alone
good dog that's a good dog good dog
that worked out fine for me i got two
kills mitch what are you
what are you doing what are you watching
i'm chasing a guy but
unsuccessfully okay rahul you have three
kills and three assists and zero deaths
right now
i don't want to talk about it when did
this happen that man
i'm pinging around to protect him i'll
try spinning that's a good trick
all right
protect now yep now finish it
keep going you got it
one crawling with buzz droids
this is where the fun begins
everybody is uh on some kind of other
layer right now i'm on the top and
everyone else is not
i feel lonely oh uh but also a bit safe
i'll come find you yeah i'm getting no
you guys want to just hang out yeah
we'll go everybody go hang out in the
station it's okay i sort of came back
down so
disregard what the [ __ ] man i'm sorry i
was on my way
the plane's gonna be partying at the
airport but i killed the guy
again congrats thank you
thank you i'm going faster than i'm
comfortable
in an interior environment just lean
into it mitch
if i lean into it i'll die like that
swerve with confidence
oh i got another one i don't deserve any
of these though i just want you guys to
know that
none of my kills thus in the this game
have been deserved they've been
stolen well i don't know about stolen
but i don't deserve them
um a bunch of
like i just sort of saw someone and
snuck up on them type [ __ ] you know
oh that's that's how you play the empire
okay that's true actually i think i'm
about to get hit we're trying to evade
we'll see how it goes
because you don't have shields right so
the best way to get an advantage is to
sneak up on somebody and burst down
their shields and kill them
i got them okay
we doing evades we're looking for
someone
where'd he go you got him nice white
onion
okay why uh why dangerous onion
i i told this story earlier um a while
ago
my friend it comes up a lot yes and also
it's such a long it's a it's a
long-winded ramble i'll try to shorten
it but
essentially my friend gave me uh a
decorative onion from my desk at work a
while ago
and i was like what the [ __ ] is a
decorative onion that's hilarious
it's an onion that is decorative like
you don't eat it and she's like no it's
not an onion it's a
genetically modified asparagus that
looks like an onion
that just sits on top of some dirt when
it gets big and i'm like that's [ __ ]
hilarious
hold up so it's but it's still like some
kind of
vegetable is what you're telling me kind
of you can't eat it though it's just
there to look at
it's decorative okay i still have a lot
of questions but me too
okay i don't have answers for you
i changed my steam name to decorative
onion and then i almost got my first
rampage in dota 2 and i started
referring to myself as a dangerous onion
okay i love it even funnier to me
i'm in support of it uh mitch i could
use heels if uh
if that's an option well i've got great
news for you pierce i'm playing a tie
interceptor and can't do
[ __ ] anything cool guess i'll kill
myself um
i didn't realize that
someone has to acknowledge this yeah yes
sir
you have one of the most delightful
voices i've ever heard
wow you have an amazing voice right well
thank you there you go i don't know what
to say to that i'm just oh gosh
have you ever done voiceover work or
anything
no you should like i've read scripts at
ign but i've never done like performance
things
did you have a review voice that you
you that you'd pull you know some people
at ign had particularly this is what
they sound like yeah yeah
no i tried guys i got hyper active again
30 years
by the way thirty to eight god damn
yeah we crushed that's good stuff
uh i tried to get rid of my review voice
because it's yeah
so inhuman some people get real floaty
it was definitely a thing
level five hell yeah
you five two piers [ __ ] yeah let's do
fleece yeah yeah do you guys mind if i
go to the bathroom real quick
yeah i was gonna get a water and then
mel is gonna give us
it was the quick rundown okay we can do
that let's take five
yep
hey everyone what's up it's me
how you all doing i'm back other people
are not yet backed by the seamstiff
sounds of things
mel is maybe back i'm unclear
em
hey fam
um i'm really liking this game so far so
that's cool
but uh
um probably shouldn't have decided to
drink before it but i was very excited
to play a game with mitch because we
haven't aged and made good friends
and it's a friday and i've had a lot of
work lately
better than battlefront 2. i mean it's
to me it feels like a completely
different game so i don't even really
feel like you can necessarily compare
them i
would say i enjoy dogfighting more than
i've enjoyed multiplayer modes in
um battlefront 2 did i say battlefield 2
i'm in battlefront 2
who knows how many ship classes and
options are there a lot
more than i expected got any plans this
weekend just work
why ea's garbage are you being paid
absolutely not you could uh sue me for
quite a bit of money
getting a lot of money if i said i
wasn't being paid for something i was
being paid for
no i just really like video games and um
as it turns out
despite my many qualms with ea they make
good video games
or have you know the mass effect trilogy
is
i mean i shot all over andromeda but we
don't forget about that also i used to
love battlefield
i really did battlefield 1942 was the
first type of shooter i played online
and i loved it hello
welcome back oh everyone's back
oh good timing oh nice we did it
everybody
look at us go
all right so we're doing some kind of
different situation now mel what's
happening
okay so fleet battles is uh it's
probably going to be a little bit harder
but great you guys are ready oh okay
eventually it's our ranked mode and it's
uh got a few different objectives other
than killing players that's part of it
but we're going to need to do is uh kill
players and also kill their capital
ships
so uh those are my babies and we're
going to fight them and kill them
great it's killing so there's yeah so
essentially every time uh you'll see
when we get into the map but there's
going to be a bar at the top of the
screen
and that's going to show us uh basically
when is the right time to attack their
capital ships versus when is the right
time to defend our capital ships from
them
okay are you the fire will move in
either direction the moor kills one of
us
either side gets pretty much cool yeah
burst cannon or guided burst cannon
uh if you're having trouble hitting your
targets guided just keep in mind it does
have a lower
damage rate output so you'll have to hit
people more often
with it but it's guided so that should
be easier
uh mitch how did you write the
characters
i just wanted to sound like i had an
important question
how did that uh happen i was trying to
think about like a really dumb and
reductive answer but i can't even think
of that
uh pull a stephen king and just say i
don't know i'll just write it
i don't know they just they you know
they really
uh i mean we knew we wanted to do
ensemble stuff
for the campaign like there was going to
be a lot of characters on both sides so
we
made sure that they all had different
archetypes and personality types and
things would be fun
together when you're like out in the out
in a mission and everyone's been
entering and cracking jokes and they've
you know they have a history so they've
all
got a rapport together um
is that difficult to write fake-based
advance
uh yeah especially because video game
writing is constantly a balance between
information and
just general interesting storytelling
right right you want to be able to talk
about a character
like express themes or uh emotions
through characters but also they also
have to be performing
under fire and that you need to restack
your bombs
yeah yeah i mean rahul and i have spoken
about this before about even doing um vo
for gears
was occasionally uh just a lot of
hey we need to get moving hey we should
move yeah
yep hey what if we went over here it
might have been for you
no i'm no i'm saying that you had to say
those lines not that they were said to
you
you're telling me files didn't get out
of any direction
no good rebuttal brilliant
[Laughter]
because i was in character the whole
time right he's [ __ ] method
in it but yeah no i can imagine that
being um
being a tough balance to strike like
i've written uh
three short stories this year that i
like there are many more
drops that are terrible [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] awesome thank you
there's one that i think i'll publish
but three that i actually like and um
yeah certainly a balance of like
information dumping and
also making sure characters make sense
and being like how do i explore their
relationship while not making it boring
and
it's yeah this stuff is more complicated
than people think that's why short
stories are so [ __ ] impossible to me
but also
so incredibly appealing well the thing
that i did about it was doing
24 hours in 20 pages yeah
i was just doing them in a very small
span of time the first one was in
i think like january i just just did it
one night
yeah i was just like i'm just do it um
that i enjoy i enjoy the challenge of it
yeah yeah it's good stuff all right i'm
going back to my regular tie fighter
because i feel like well i did well with
the bubble
i will play the reaper and i will do my
best to keep everybody alive
why does my uh bomber currently say max
speed
minus 23 ah so you might have
a a hull or engine or no not shield
holler engine equipped that would
that alters your your basically max
output
and gives you something else instead so
it's kind of a player so it's just not
telling me what i have increased
you you're looking at the slam what
did you have this if you've got uh if
you've got just like you're hovering
over the ship right now and you've got
like max pearl xp mixed with celery so
whatever has the green
like bar on it is what you've got
nothing has green
yeah that's why i'm like why is this one
minus have i not gained anything
do you have any text at the very bottom
that tells you a bonus like i have
passive discharge regeneration
that's also what i have would that be it
okay oh that would be it then okay
got it yeah yeah yeah there we go
let's do it awesome it'd be amazing if
you didn't build a kit that was just
like you're worse
everything is terrible you [ __ ] up the
story of my life man
so yeah we're just gonna uh want to kill
the enemy team as fast as possible
and not die thank you
[Laughter]
you are going to do that we will uh
watch and applaud from a distance
yeah and be very proud of you we don't
need the commander vo in this game we
just need mel
do you like to be the commander vo i
used to be the scratch vio for the game
yeah
i guess that's the voice acting i've
done is doing the scratch vo for our
game
yeah that's a common thing people make
people interested
cool i like frisk there you go
all right i'm going to find their small
capital ships
so we're going to reach is this what i'm
this is like a halo situation
yeah we're moving to like the middle of
the battlefield did you
not you really didn't acknowledge my
halo reference [ __ ]
[Laughter]
absolutely where we're going for the
first stage
okay thank you i seriously appreciate
the sound out of reach
i really like that yeah okay i'm being
beeped at
stop can you leave me alone whoop
i died oh the question yeah i that
wouldn't have happened if i didn't
completely lose track of you
everything so the corvette is going to
be pretty dangerous
i recommend we if you've got bombers try
and hit that as fast as you can it
should be the little ship with the star
on it
all right so we need to defend our
medium-sized capital ships
do you see them i'll ping them
the uh the empire the cruisers okay
so we're gonna try and find any bombers
coming towards us like this guy
and we're gonna try and kill them as
fast as we can ready go
all right where are we headed we're
killing formula cats
is the plan formula cats killed me
excellent
um i've lost formula cats there we go
you son of a [ __ ]
still out of range any minute now oh
he's got a mod to make himself harder to
target okay he's disabled if anyone can
get on him i bought him
i'm also on him i think we'll be all
right i think we got this smell
hell yeah we got him i think you do too
nice oh my god
i'm dead oh i like this ball it's
good i feel good about it yeah we're
doing good we just got a good boost
so should i take out the stall
yeah kill that star [ __ ] it up
still out of range here we go
yeah so that small ship is gonna deal
a significant amount of damage medium
damage
yeah these things are pretty deadly okay
i'll help you thank you any players that
come near it
appreciate you for you oh
we got a ewing coming at the corvette
never mind jesus see you later
formula cats oh [ __ ]
he got me don't [ __ ] die pierce i'm
here i'm trying not to
i'm trying to do as much damage as
possible did my health not go to you god
damn it it said recharging
but there we go this is good defense
we'll get a big morale boop
oh did we destroy it okay okay got it
got it got it got it yeah look at
thank you mitch that was very helpful um
all right
all right now kill these people kill
this idiot
tell me who to kill and i will do it i
would die for you
uh anything you want me to do i'm i'm
there
oh no i'm not against [ __ ] you on the
internet
[Laughter]
whoever's in a thai bomber crashed into
me well i'm gonna tie bomber but i did
not crash into you
it's okay i put in some work there i
deserve to die
sometimes it's okay oh yes as an
important note i should have mentioned
earlier um
if we get too close to the enemy capital
ships while our morale is not high
enough
uh we will die very fast uh i definitely
did that earlier noted
okay yeah i really like this i'm super
into this mug this
is cool it's like a tug of war pretty
much yeah
i have zero kills i'm getting
yeah i've been meaning to speak to you
about that raw hole
good both our capital ships are going
down let's hey coley let's take out
formula cats
currently out of range for me but i'm
going for it i'm on him okay stay behind
and then i will go from the front
if i can get there any minute now
okay great the plan is not going as
planned
as it turns out ship quite fast
[Laughter]
all right
i'm [ __ ] dying nah dude
oh uh to the person in my chat who say
uh i seem more like a dog person
thank you uh i really appreciate that
you do steam more like a cat person [ __ ]
off
yeah but i know why are you coming at me
like that she's saying that all right
you know that's not true oh okay okay
so we take out their frigates yes the
frigates are a little
bit interesting to take out because
they're a weird shape
but if you've got a bomber i do
yeah hit that thing as fast and hard as
you can oh i see it doesn't look
watch this formula cast is pretty good
where did frigate go where is frigate
how have i lost it oh i am too close to
frigate
i got pretty close to frigate also oh i
was attacking the wrong thing
that's what happened oh yeah they're the
weird skinny ships
yep yep it was probably a mistake of
mine
so early on in just to play instrument
mode
oh god oh yeah yeah yeah i've been
playing instrument mode this whole time
that's insane what i'm taking a lot of
fire right now but i'm also doing a lot
of damage so i felt okay with it
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you like cats dude yeah
you did great you got almost all the
shields down
thank you thank you that is what i like
to see
i do have a lot of cap ship damage i
just would like to get more credit for
that
my cap ship damage is very high um but
everything else is terrible
oh the lord god uh i'm flying here
fight to me fly to me
live damn you thank you fricking it's
freaking sick okay
we're good we're good stop cussing raw
hole that's inappropriate
before it gets riggets kind of became a
cuss word over development
did it really yeah
what else are we supposed to attack i
can't see anything i just counted a
missile
i successfully did it still out of range
i'm gonna get a formula cast is going
down he's gonna ah
i thought that i dodged that but i did
not okay we're back to defense now
yes ma'am all right
raul let's turn around we're about to
fly today
i'm going to die sorry
mel no i understand
completely this would be easier if we
had a fifth player
i mean i could probably probably find
one
so what are we doing now keys are
defending so any
no coming towards our ship [ __ ] them up
i boosted uh right away oh no
[Laughter]
it was i mean i was entertained by it
but it was bad it was bad
why am i so far away from everything
come on oh hold up are we a squad of
four
against the squad of five ah mel please
please carry us extra hard oh lord
[ __ ] cruiser down uh chat rahul is not
also streaming
um he was a mix of streamer uh and thus
lost his platform r.i.p
i did suggest that which i still kind of
stand by because it's like it's not like
you were like looking for your job
like on streaming it was like very much
a hobby type situation
and i think mixer is the best tech i
want to be an actor
did you oh well you should have
communicated that with me probably
mel you have a twitch as well right but
you're not currently streaming
i don't i yeah i do but i'm not
currently streaming
um it's just mel rambles mel rambles
that's me
no mel rams mel rams oh is it male rams
yeah we
we looked this up the other day because
we always get some guys for the same
reasons i'm sorry
i've given misinformation
twitch.tv rams that's the one nailed it
first first try got it right on the
first try
high five oh my god gang we don't have
any cruisers we lost our defenses
yes santa tucci is just destroying me
now
stanley tucci stanley oh tooncie
you love toon chicholi family tucci is
ionized and i am [ __ ] exploded wow
like i kicked my ass
i'll kick his ass thank you somebody
kicks my friend's ass
i don't think we was ready for this i
committed suicide and didn't even know
how
my bad there is a practice mode and a
tutorial like this
we're really diving in the deep end yeah
hey scooterman gaming you shot your
[ __ ] mouth
they made fun of me for only getting a
kill at the start of the game have you
seen the points that i have though
okay look at that capture damage that i
got all right
caption of damage will win the round
don't sass me
i love playing to the objective what i
really do it's important to me actually
but i am significantly improving in
terms of missile evasion you guys please
be proud of me
um you can send fan mail to um
carolinas.hotmail.com which is an email
address that exists for my xbox live
account exclusively that i don't use
um but you could send fan mail there if
you really wanted nobody would read it
but you could send it nope but you could
send it technically
if you wanted to waste part of your life
on this earth you could email
that uh where am i getting i do have a
public business email address
i [ __ ] that up i didn't even know what
i was doing um but that goes to directly
to my manager and sometimes people will
like send dick pics and i love it
because it goes to a team of three men
not me
they're just sending it to three dudes
your managers yes forever
we've spoken you we had to ban you for
several several times you just won't
stop
doing it but really it's literally three
dudes who are like
well um sometimes i'll see text in our
little text red that'll like some dude i
guess sent photos of him wearing
female underwear um and they were like
nobody read that one
i'm like i don't see any of it it's
great
not my problem i love that yeah big fan
man i wish i had a team of dudes stream
screening dick pics for me it's pr it's
pretty handy
i'll be honest i feel sorry for them
because i think that i'm the first
female they've managed and they're like
we didn't we didn't see this coming
but it's definitely a thing i'm [ __ ]
over this
oh well have you thought about getting
good
uh i shouldn't be doing that that's a
bad idea that's a bad idea all right
well we're going to kill shed beasts are
you ready i'm going for should be
solstice oh i have to wait until
i respawn out of range still
so usually we need to kill the y wings
before they reach our star destroyer
uh inter you usually want like two or
three interceptors on defense
and a couple of tie fighters or at least
one support ship
um i keep committing yeah it really
helps
um
it doesn't feel like any of them are
coming to us though they're
they're they're kind of going under the
ship um
and working their way oh yeah there's
one stanley tucci
stanley tucci's done someone in my chat
asks how can you tell who's winning
though
i mean they would be winning right now
that's correct if they're over your
capital
then yeah you're losing but it
technically does sort of alter all the
time
which it does i like actually you can
also see if you press start kind of the
status of the ships
yeah exactly um so we've defended
successfully
we get another shot at destroying their
mid caps if we can get their mid caps
we can get to their flagship and get to
their flagship
i need to restock i'm going to be a suck
oh
i'm spinning i'm spinning that's a spin
that's happening and i'm trying not to
spin did my controller
stop working nope we're good okay it did
for a second there
everything's fine yeah i have a i don't
know why i haven't changed it
i have uh definitely have a connection
issue with this controller specifically
oh did you forget i
you and me mitch out here yeah
yeah yeah i actually feel like i'm doing
okay so
i have 13 000 capture damage
that's awesome it's pretty [ __ ] good
my question was going to be i don't
understand why i'm not directly below
mel in in terms of the current ranking
um but it doesn't really matter
if the answer is involving math i cannot
help you yeah okay we got one
okay we lost we lost controller again
come on buddy please come back it's
nothing right it's disabled
come on bud come on i have been blown up
there we go it's back okay
okay okay oh oh no oh oh i opened game
ball
okay nearly destroyed on the right so
close
i have a name
thanks mel i appreciate you
[ __ ] that was all bad all bad it's
already got 50
health if we can stay alive for a little
bit longer we should be able to get to
it
and so yeah i'm third on on our ranking
second most but i have is it
because mitch has more assist than me
this i'm unclear on why
my score is that much lower than mitch's
when we have the same deaths but i have
more kills and more caps
frequently see like plus 25 or plus 50
for various things
sometimes it's kills sometimes it's
assist sometimes it's like
there's one for barrage there's one for
i think there's stuff for like helping
your team
uh there is stuff for healing it's like
every other thing gives you points okay
but some of them are just bigger cash
ins got it
i think kills are the biggest and smell
our uh our flagship's in rough shape i'm
not gonna lie this might be our last
stand
so just uh picking well we're on the
defensive [ __ ] i didn't realize
yeah i need to bail all the way up i
need to bail
i'm in the danger zone yeah i [ __ ] up
as well
[ __ ] at least we died
i mean the ui is still pretty [ __ ]
oh i counted one and then got done by
another the ui still pretty clean even
when you're not playing on the mode
you're playing on rahul
um yeah it's it's tidy
there's some information but it's all
where it needs to be
yeah there's so much information too so
it's like
it's it's tidy but it is quite a lot to
process
you guys talking about [ __ ]
rottweilers in chat it's like one of my
favorite brands of dog
the corvette is powerful holy [ __ ]
they're small but they strunk it's true
very strong
oh never mind i'm dumb i thought i was
under the shield and i was not
shields are gone by the way they got one
of our shield generators god damn it
um it's cool people are figuring out
where to attack yeah yeah them sub
systems
they're important okay so what should i
be doing right now just like sort of
hanging back waiting
to attack okay yeah yeah and if you
don't see any players you can find some
ai creeps and just
their auto shields got it a small amount
of morale boost as well
also this corvette's got to go it's
difficult it's like right up in our [ __ ]
right
i was seeing that correctly nicole that
was right there
[ __ ] you reaper got him nice
or whatever that was good stuff
we didn't have a [ __ ] cat we didn't
have a [ __ ] you formula cats
i agree we'll play it down from the
beginning [ __ ] you formula cats
significantly harder absolutely
wanna jack [ __ ] you guys bunch of people
hey guys i got hyperactive again
dangerous onion 27 kills good [ __ ]
yeah
just god bless just really thankful for
you and all of your work
really appreciate it it's you know what
it's nice to be appreciated
uh someone in my chat asked if i'm using
secondary weapons
am i i'm using right trigger and i'm
using right bumper that's it
yeah right battery is your secondary
weapon yep got it
what's your second bum what's your
what's the second thing so there's
artilleries
and there's secondary weapons i'm not
using leftover oh
oh that's uh that's a self-heal huh
that sounds handy actually oh yeah i
definitely did know that with the x-wing
but i guess that also works with attack
fighter
yeah there you go kind of default on
most of them
yeah you can switch switch it out uh
when you start customizing but that
should be there
thank you appreciate that uh
fake alameros most recent podcast is not
private i just have to re-upload because
i accidentally uploaded last week's
episode
we want to do another fleet battles yeah
i liked that it was fun
okay that's [ __ ] good
[Laughter]
we have one girl yeah all right
against bots that will be don't okay
don't condescend us
all right okay captain 20 [ __ ]
thousand kills or whatever okay
it's an option i'd rather do training
uh someone called moff asked are we
going to get info on the health and
damage stats of the capital ships
uh i'm i'm probably i'm gonna leave that
for now
all right probably not but
uh i i think it's important at least to
me
that like i let some of the public just
figure it out on their own
and see see what people come up with
and yeah i respect that i respect that
i want i want there to be an element of
discovery and surprise yeah let's see
what
components people start using and what
team comps they start forming
yeah the competitive play for this game
could get super interesting because it
is
like i said earlier like way more
customizable than i even thought it
would be
it it would get pretty crazy uh when we
were doing
internal play sessions we had like a a
team
of folks that played regularly and we
all were trying different builds and we
had like a huge spreadsheet to figure
out what
like make sure nothing felt overpowered
nothing was underpowered it was
oh it was a lot of fun yeah i mean a lot
of work
i i feel like i need to sit down and
read through these menus
in a lot of time and be like which of
these things do i care about and why
because right now if we're back to
x-wings i'm just using a regular
a regular i haven't customized this at
all i'm like just let me get used to
this [ __ ] before i start customizing
like do i want more
exactly do i want more acceleration do i
want this
it's uh i'm impressed i'm impressed
uh jeff asked his mel ever had to carry
a team like this before
i don't know what you're referring to
jeff um i
i think we're all equally rolling out
on our way so i don't know what you're
talking about
to be honest it's pretty rude um
mel is doing you know just as good as
anyone else on the team
except significantly better
sure she says
not wrong yeah oh there it is
all right it's happened here we go
i just got a reinforced hull hey gang
our fifth player left
great all righty then
i love that for us
[Music]
that might be me oh no
are you on a loading screen are you in
the menu fleet battles loading
screen oh that's true oh no yeah i think
we're okay it just happened suddenly
yeah matches just started oh yeah i mean
i mean
there we go there she goes
there she blows all right there's yeah
there are still four of us
yeah let me see i think there's only
four yeah there's only four on the other
team too so it's even
oh that's handy it's interesting because
i wouldn't say that i feel that the
matches are particularly tuned for
four players i feel like five is just
better yeah then you can have a healer
or
an extra bomber but we'll make it work
you are both dota players
uh what's the ideal strat at the
beginning of the game like what how do
we
how do we destroy it yes
exactly what is that laning phase like
absolutely laning phases go for
player kills above all else oh okay i
wasn't
so noted great oh yeah the uh
the small capital ships like the raider
is is a priority as well it gives you a
big boost
but i would i would say like have three
people on player kills and two people on
that
okay well i died so it's uh the opposite
of what you said
but i did damage to someone also
um you're welcome every little bit
counts
i have to i got i got a score of 10.
so yeah i mean it happened
all right i like the x-wing
that makes me really feel at home
oh that's lovely yeah
[Music]
all right hey mitch you will be miss
i did some healing hey that's good
we love that
he was so close to death [ __ ] you we man
uh oh that's a pole
oh god i'm coming to you rojo but no
never mind
i'm gonna let him go oh no alana no bad
across the board there
none of that all right no no
no no no no okay hey
when i'm bad at video games at least
nobody is ever harsher on me than me
[Laughter]
god words all right let's kill murky
he's in a bomber he's a priority
[ __ ] i'm going for it yeah [ __ ] him up
oh [ __ ] i'm all the same
i'm dead this is super fun you guys i
really enjoy playing this
i i recognize that i have a lot to learn
and that's the thing that i need to do
but i'm having a good time
are you okay there rahul are these good
screams or bad screams
wedge are they touching you
on me you [ __ ]
this is i'm not doing well
bless you oh i thank you i'll see you
again
thank you as well bless you
oh lord
okay that's what i'm saying bro monkey's
a [ __ ]
i hate murky [ __ ] you
oh [ __ ] murky all right what's the
status of them thanks mitch
yeah man this is the trident
is 35 finish it off
we got now our free gets in three gets
our frigates are in good shape did we
get it
down yeah he's backing down
explosives there he is is he down down
he's there now he's down oh [ __ ] all
mine
i killed my raiders oh
oh from hell's we're about to attack
let's go let's go okay attacking
what are we attacking the triangles
uh cruisers yeah my brain stopped
working
yeah because rahul doesn't know anything
about star wars you're going to have to
explain everything in shapes
otherwise he won't uh understand what
you're saying pizza pies rahul
i'm shooting the pizza pie is that
helpful
[ __ ] you marcus got a little cooked but
i'm okay all right
mother was a hamster and your father
smelled of elderberries
[ __ ] explosives suck your mum
suck your mum he says
oh they're they're good from afar yeah
they are like a camper they are quite
good [ __ ]
salty palms son of a [ __ ]
[ __ ] surely i'm out of range i'm coming
from a gun
uh somebody might have asked if it's
only first person it is right
yes yes yes you know i like this
perspective
that's the only way it should be i'm
x-wing thai fight are all of them
purists i'm surprised you know what they
are
aren't you like the x-shaped one oh yeah
and the circle one with the bits on the
side
i like the i like the cross one yes the
cross one
is nice i'm really
i'm really letting you guys down cap
ship damage is still
great though crushing it with the
capture damage yeah
a player abandoned the game why did i
just get that notification
it happened a while ago oh that's a
bummer because now the mmr doesn't count
for the for the ranked calibration oh
bummer it's fine
yeah whatever dude we're playing the
game we're chilling we're getting xp
that's all i care about really [ __ ]
no stop it
all right gotta hear apollo you think
you're cool with your cool name that's
actually very cool
you think you're cool with some merit
whoa okay we're cool we're good
paula's got 67 health i'm gonna [ __ ] him
up
wow that self-heal has uh really changed
my life
did not know okay preparing to defend
wait wait have i am i not taking you
down yet oh
that was my fault [ __ ]
jersey accent i don't know what a jersey
accent sounds like
it's a person in my chat requested a
jersey accent um
yeah i mean i feel like new york sort of
sounds like this or is this more like
boston
because i'm foreign i still don't really
know what they sound like
in the east coast because i've never
lived there
right i don't know i'm foreign that's
you're asking a lot of me
and i also always sound like a dude i
don't know why what are we what are we
supposed to do now
uh we gotta defend our frigates yeah so
take out the raider
and take out that raider okay
take out that raider where's the radar
um i'll ping it once i see it
pinged it got it got it got it
it is all over b at the moment yeah it's
a b
we got this we got this how'd you like
that wheel man
wheel man real man
a wheel man a real life man
get away from it come on oh i did it i
am getting much better at evading
i am not
[Laughter]
i'm not
all right come on buddy
yeah raider [ __ ] you eight seven six
five four three two got it bye [ __ ]
nice work
holy beautiful work that was satisfying
yeah i feel good about that one
i like this can of these cannons you
recommended mel nice
yeah they've like my kills have gone up
uh considerably
it's really satisfying hey yeah for sure
good stuff oh my god stop blocking on me
you sons of [ __ ]
oh cruiser time [ __ ] pizza time
okay so we're just supposed to just
hammer these
yeah pierce but you got it too uh
[Music]
so much damage onto the capital ships
i'm going to try and put something on
this oh [ __ ]
i do have 22 000 cap damage but i also
have seven deaths
thanks mitch pierce you are avenged
uh someone said that my side of my
reticle will expand when i'm in range
okay i should pay more attention [ __ ]
explosives
he's just picking everyone off from
across the other side of that i don't
know what he's using
oh if you see a little there's a circle
red thing on the map that's a mine
all right we can take this [ __ ]
out for sure yep
y'all this game is real fun i just feel
like a power slide on this station that
was [ __ ] awesome
nice work this this cruiser's only got
20 health
oh 15. i'm dead we're gonna we're
getting it we're getting it i don't even
care that i have a missile locked i'm
gonna [ __ ] kill this [ __ ]
it's so oh i'm not no i have to bail
that's all good we have plenty of morel
our corvette's still up we're in a good
spot
one cruiser down perfect
yeah i'm putting work there i'll put in
one i'm proud of me
you are contributing i'm contributing to
the team
assault star destroyer oh
yes this is great okay so i'm gonna hit
a couple targets on this ship
i'll ping him i'm dying you guys gonna
contribute [ __ ]
i'm dying more i promise but we're doing
good i feel good about this
we can bring this back yeah for sure
we do not have a rule and we are down
with another player
uh yeah well yeah because rahul died
right so there's only three of us right
now we should wait
wait so we're all alive all right it's
going to expand
it's great for the install destroyer yes
so yeah
it's got shields which we can take out
using the the shield generators or you
can just hit it
like straight up and it'll go down
eventually get the shield generator so
it won't come back otherwise it rejects
thank you mitch
no oh i can't even do a straight yeah
we man doesn't look good
why have you done this to us why have
you done this
because it was fun i didn't know how
this could be so powerful
yeah who who could have guessed man
that's why the empire's so goddamn scary
it's all good i'm gonna lay a bunch of
mines around our mid cap our remaining
frigate
wait do we still have warmups yeah
that's [ __ ] awesome i also will lay
mines
apollo got me never mind two bombers
coming in yeah two bombers that's a lot
of damage that's a lot of damage
oh [ __ ] thanks mitch
no no i [ __ ] that up
it's not it's not good it's not not if
it's good
i'm not doing great um
get close where is this prick i'm going
for him he's right here
oh i see that raider yeah
ryan got it thank you there was somebody
spamming a chat i had to deal with that
seems like it's okay i'm shocked with
how far these guys shoot
from like i get right up like at their
tail
it's i think is it the gun that you're
using rahul i think it has a shorter
burst
is that it mel it has shorter range
sorry the burst
uh you know what i don't remember i
think it has a shorter fire range so
they're going to have
to stop the same experience today too oh
[ __ ]
ah [ __ ] off god damn it
there's a guy underneath just stop
locking missiles on me you [ __ ] i know
that i'm going through the same thing
every two seconds yeah another one
but i am getting better at paying off
television
[ __ ] i think i'm getting lost
oh it's like 13. it's [ __ ] us up
right out of our uh
our hangar we should whoa [ __ ]
we should try and get this raider oh
come on come on come on
okay oh yeah taken out by apollo it's
done
how does that feel uh your god son's
taking you out
i know right i've never hated that name
more
than right now i got him
he's down you can focus on that raider
now look down down down
down down down where's that raider [ __ ]
you right up
uh it is here
already i just fallen into a
[ __ ] wonderful we're so close to
flipping man we're ready i don't know
yeah we man can [ __ ] off we managed to
get one health
down nice good job so he problems
oh [ __ ] good job
[ __ ] apollo bro my gosh
all right let's put the boost on that
may be a quick way to get there right
absolutely right so change power
and boost as an oh and i'm going to be
targeted
i didn't go
that's not boost that's boost there you
go
now this is pod racing
i'm dead so what should we be doing
right now mel literally attacking the
star destroyer
yeah literally okay i'm switching to a
bomber
we're not gonna have to support yeah
killed me
ah [ __ ] explosives man that's too
much damage like what's the
okay so what's the best way to not take
a [ __ ] ton of damage from the star
destroyer
while attacking the star destroyer yes
so the faster you're going and the more
you're weaving
the better chances to survive yeah okay
so just move around be as hyperactive as
you possibly can be
attractive that's you that's me just do
what you do best alana i
got it i'm gonna go for what's the best
one to go for
[ __ ]
so do you think i should stay on engines
while i'm doing wings are good yeah
like a truck they got big shields
they're tanky jumps like a truck truck
truck we're defending again
stop locking on me you [ __ ]
but what if enemy wasn't walking what if
then
damn it [ __ ] apollo bro
yeah really defending [ __ ] our big ship
uh kill the raider kill the bombers
that's the
priority for the raiders kill the
bombers so i go and kill a typewriter
[Laughter]
it's helpful okay where's the raider
come on explosiveness
that's nice you're not explosives
shields are down on the radar real man
where are you
there you are
nice kill [ __ ] this raider up bro
that was cool
did we get him he's getting there
we man it's coming in hot man if we get
the raider in a couple kills we can flip
it before they can even attack
wait man's down apollo
who else is there come on come on come
on come on come on raider raider raider
okay later stan yeah bring us down very
cool it was very aggressive on that
[ __ ]
i'm disabled rahul that's insensitive
are you really proud of the disabled
community i'm back i'm back i'm able
i'm back all right
let's whoa yeah attacking me
where are we going a star destroyer
destroyer all together
so when does uh when when okay i'm gonna
say
it's quite good stuff what's what's its
like alternative
thing what doesn't it bomb more anything
oh
yes yeah you get more components
mitch you resupplied me and then i just
kept running into a star destroyer
so i just want to apologize
it's the uh so the y wing has um
its secondary weapons do are like bigger
lock-on times or
are just like a bomb you drop underneath
you and they deal tons of tons of hull
damage to the capital ships
yeah so i'm going to switch to wyoming
and see what i can do
see what i can see oh oh oh ow wow
okay back whoo oh [ __ ] did i hit it
sorry no that was me i collided with you
oh i just want to shout out my own cap
ship damage yeah
it's very high um everything else is bad
wow that's your god
all right oh we're back to defending
okay
okay active defense all right
back to stop locking on me
i'm busy okay i'm trying to shoot
you know [ __ ] you got me
lord yeah apollo can go [ __ ] himself
that's my hot take at the session oh we
made it you really can
we meant to though yeah ah
we
okay okay we got some heels in get away
from me
me and this raider just been going at it
son of a [ __ ] [ __ ] wow trying to get
some damage onto that raider as well
oh lord not even getting a break
yeah oh the raider killed me
[Laughter]
got kylo ren
[Laughter]
spoilers this may be our last stand
friends but we're
making them work for it we are doing
even better than last time
oh jesus [ __ ]
deploy
there it is considering we've been five
before two games in a row
i know that's unfair we were wrong
it's pretty hard to go against the stand
up against the flagships of four people
it's possible it's just a little bit
harder
hyperactive i did get hyperactive again
yes i kept getting i keep getting max
engine power yes i did do a lot of that
thank you for noticing i appreciate it
uh zilla in my chat asked um rahul how
does it feel to be on the mandalorian
set
is this similar to that or it's one
it's one giant like oled screen
well yeah like standing in front
of best buy why are you doing that or
you're speaking
if you watch the making of you can see
what it's like you don't need my opinion
it's actually very cool like i respect
the hell out of the way that they're
making it oh you in manchester
as well yes as well
we forget her name but we replace her
with that she wants to be nice what's
that she wants her pronouns to be beat
bop boop she can go [ __ ] herself
nice a hot tape yeah
uh are we doing just the do the normal
death match
and what's going on on everyone
is it really it is okay i guess we did
start late
it was eight okay no it was late for you
i can't throw you that kind of shade it
was late for you i'm sorry
[Music]
but even if it was eight we'd be like oh
bedtime
it's almost nine oh
oh my goodness almost 9 p.m
launch adrenaline to stay awake last
couple nights
do you want to know something that's
going to turn the mood and make everyone
sad for a little bit but it happened
today
no oh okay yes then
um when i came back from the gym in the
morning i couldn't get into the building
because there's police everywhere
and someone had either fallen or jumped
from our balcony
and killed themselves and the body was
just on the
on the sidewalk oh yeah that's a brutal
that's very brutal yeah yeah and then
because you couldn't
leave the building or get in i couldn't
go out and smoke
devastating for you they must have been
really hard were you okay
it was for an hour i was absolutely like
a [ __ ] yeah
there was um one time when i was walking
back to my apartment in san francisco
the
everywhere around my apartment was like
locked off
uh by police tape and there had been a
car accident
and all i saw aside from the car which
was smashed into a pole
was a hand from about or i guess an arm
about elbow
up just laying in the middle of the road
oh lord but that's it
i didn't see anything else i just saw
that and i remember like walking into my
pop and i had to get through and had
police had to like permit me to
to come under the tape dude so i could
get in my apartment and uh just like
standing outside the door for a while
just thinking about what i had seen and
just being like
[ __ ] hell like someone just straight
up got into a car accident there's just
a hand on the road it was [ __ ] up it's
like it took me a while to get over that
one
it's not a not a fun thing to see hope
you're okay
yeah drive safe and um
don't jump off buildings there's my hot
pieces
well they might have fallen as well we
someone in my chat said that the dog had
diarrhea all day
so that's you know that's a bomber too
um
you have to consider bummers across the
board
dogs having diarrhea does suck that is
very inconvenient
having diarrhea but you don't understand
what that is
yup so you don't know when it's going to
come out of why
[Laughter]
just miserable yeah until you're not
i always wish that i could tell dogs
that certain things that they just
shouldn't do
like what if you didn't eat plastic
buddy
you shouldn't be doing it i'm out here
trying to stop you from doing i know
you're mad because you like chewing
plastic
but it's gonna make your shits bad stop
doing it
make us feel better please yes all right
w's please
this is on you i would like a w please
ah it's for kids okay great my
controller stopped walking again i love
that that happens
let's uh plug it back in how about now
how about now
there we go there she is let's [ __ ]
man's up
all right kill this idiot hey we have a
teammate with us and everything
wow
oh lord all right is that the username
oh i thought rahul was
actually talking about his butthole for
no reason okay got it it's a username
oh i had the whole squad on me jeez
duh my own fault i'm in hot pursuit with
this guy and i probably should just give
up but
yes everyone's favorite needs to be
oh no i'm a [ __ ] idiot no i'm bad
i've been meaning it i'm good
everything's fun most of the damage i've
taken this round has been
just me crashing into things so
got another one okay i guess that guy
and i killed each other
five health sure wasn't gonna lost i
wasn't gonna last
i got him i smash it into him i love it
when that happens
doesn't doesn't happen often in any way
you've already got three kills
[ __ ] oh my gosh
how does she do it
i'm just trying to make you guys feel
better you're helping it's working
quite well this is what make other
people feel bad
so my friends thank you
[Music]
appreciate it this is great because it
it
it speaks to both sides of my brain
which is i want to make people happy and
i want to make people suffer
at all times this gives me a good outlet
for that uh-huh
dad see you bro oh nice
i can't get a lock on anyone right now
kill this idiot i think mel's just
killing them all is why
yeah this guy alive you get him you get
him oh ow [ __ ]
the pirates
yeah i relate to that they stay in the
same spot and they respawn after on a
timer you can see like a white circle
inside of it
have i got no [ __ ] kills
gotta get good dude
you've got no kills shut up all right
nobody was talking about that
so i don't know why you felt the need to
alana i think that maybe i've had too
much alcohol and it's all been downhill
for the last couple of games there was a
point where i was all right but i don't
know that that's success
battles and the limit with your sobriety
and it was all downhill on there
holy [ __ ] i cannot kill anyone to save
my life
um why don't you equip some mines and
start leaving those around
[ __ ] [ __ ] i've gotten some assists
i had them on my interceptor i just
didn't feel like i was being effective
with them but my gosh if i could avoid
people
[Music]
and another one's missile locking so
circle of life really oh
you're being targeted again man people
are just [ __ ] going after leave me
alone
no she's learning literally
you [ __ ] oh god damn it
okay that's fair i killed tingledy
butthole like six times
all right okay all right we got it
don't touch it be all
i generally have like a decent iron
stomach for vr
uh but flying in 3d space for extended
periods of time
that'll do it to you yeah but it's
something i'll get this brick on my tail
please
like i'm i'm after him oh
all right tap tap tap a and then hit y
oh wait you're on a flight stick [ __ ]
i'm sorry ah [ __ ]
i was so close to getting that [ __ ]
heel and this who's this pretty [ __ ]
stopped me right before i got my heel i
keep forgetting that i have um i have
shield boost with uh
oh yeah with an axe wing damn it [ __ ]
anyway i was on my way
i failed
you hiding look at you camping how do
you camp in a flight sim
you're [ __ ] weirdo
pretty close we're tied right now yeah
well you know because one of us has 10
kills
[Music]
[ __ ] you know you're having a tough time
there coley
yeah oh alana
oh you stupid [ __ ] i think i see the
people chasing you i'm going after them
you will live thank you
leave me alone leave me alone bro stop
locking on me
no i just really i'm at a point where
it's not you know it's not good
because i just keep running into rocks i
guess that's also just this particular
uh
this map is very rocky yeah
just i feel like i'm deserving some of
these you know [ __ ]
it's all good at least with with these
like the physics are
kind of bouncy so you don't die as soon
as you type like clip something
yeah it's true yeah you bounce you
bounce it's a little more forgiving
than a starfighter assault in that sense
i see you're out i'm coming don't tempt
me bro i will tingle the [ __ ] out of
your butthole
i got it got me no i [ __ ] avenged you
then damn it
yeah i can't do anything just having
that get the type of game
yeah i'm relating to that i feel uh
trying so hard
i'm really trying to do it
all right i got him nice work
we're catching up
yeah we just need to stay alive
and we'll be all right stop talking me
it's so
rude uh oh i'm on him no i
hated it was that because of you well
thank you bless you
he's dead thank you
you mean i have aided it you did it
victory is imminent yeah we're pulling
ahead
don't touch
oh thanks just looking for someone to
kill oh
nice my mom got him good job bomb
very cool even your bums are putting in
work
oh my god my favorite thing is when you
get into a dog fight
and you're kind of in a death loop where
you're both spinning around you just
leave a mine
and eventually they'll spin into it and
it's just so satisfying
that is good one more kill
right now i'm just debating people i
haven't even seen anyone here we go
there's someone that's perfect oh
it's butthole he's gonna beat the
killing blow here we go
he's dead yeah
victory look at us
all so good at this game nothing but w
yes
everyone equally good at this video game
yes that is what is we are all very good
in agreement across the board
talented no fake gamers
in this call [ __ ] you tinkle me butthole
[Laughter]
um all right you guys i feel like i
should bounce to eat some food
and also let you guys go because how
long we've been playing yeah we should
bounce to go to sleep
to sleep right yeah we've been playing
two and a half hours almost this was
really fun like i had a great time
playing it
i definitely need to learn but um yeah
i'd be down to play again if you guys
want to at some point
that would be cool hit us up if you want
to play all weekend
that sounds wonderful yeah yeah
yeah we'll be online we'll be our round
cool you'd love to see it
yeah i'll send you a cute little text um
no raw holes allowed
um cool wow everyone but but wrong would
be
super cool so i got mates you can [ __ ]
i've got
uh i'm friends with uh pedro pascal
because you're working because you're
working together on the mandalorian or
oh i'm just friends with them got it
unrelated
noted anyway so
goodbye everyone